(crackling)
- Hey, I'm Deckard.
Movieleaks.com.
Here we are with
the lovely Gillian.
- Hi. Good to see you.
- I've got, uh, questions.
First question is, is
First Date a romcom?
- Yeah.
- Okay, then I guess I don't
have any other questions.
(lively music)
(sexy rock music)
- Wow, Britney,
what's with your hair?
It's huge.
It's like that hair
ate your other hair.
- Okay, FYI, everyone,
I'm feeling very insecure today.
And you know how I'm normally
the most confident
woman in America?
- Yes. Mm-hmm.
- But when this
bitch comes to town?
- Gillian Jacobs?
Doesn't everybody love her?
- That goblin face?
Hell, no.
- I kind of think
she's a sweetheart.
- Seems really cool.
- Kinda sexy, I
mean, I like her.
She's got a really good smile.
- She's really cool.
She is a favorite.
- Well, trust me, she's,
like, my best friend.
She's awful.
- Oh, wait, that's right.
You were in that
sitcom with her.
Uh, Blame it on Baxter.
(laughing)
Wait, you played--
- Fatty Fanny, yes.
What kind of sick
fuck comedy writer
names a overweight
12-year-old Fatty?
Like, that was my
given name on the show.
It's so fucked up.
Oh, my God.
- Hey, hey.
- I ate a muffin.
- It's okay, it's
okay, it's okay.
- Take it.
- Hey, what's up, Dork Squad?
Everyone is here.
- Okay, Kevin?
Honestly, don't start with me.
- Mmm, Fatty Fanny's got
her panties in a bunch.
Are you ready for
your big reunion?
(coughs)
Porkie?
- I cannot even right now.
(lively music)
Oh, my God.
- Wow.
- [Britney] Gilli.
- What a blast from the past.
Ow.
- Oh, my God, it's
so good to see you.
Honestly, like, I
really missed you.
- Good to see you.
- You look amazing.
- Oh, so do you.
- Oh, my God, your
skin is so amazing.
I want to, like, wear
you like a jacket.
- What?
Oh, my God, this is so exciting.
- Yes, very exciting.
First Date.
- I thought it was good.
- Oh, great.
I'm so glad.
- Totally, like, you know,
not gonna get a lot of praise.
It's not gonna, like,
hurt your career too much.
- I always count on you
to give me straight up--
- Yes, because that's,
like, our dynamic, right?
- Yeah. You're a little mean,
and I just take it.
- I finally finished book
23 of the Glanthor Saga.
- Oh, congratulations on that.
Am I supposed to be interested
in that stupid
book you're writing
in your mom's basement
about dragons?
- Alright, they're not
called "dragons" in Glanthor.
They're called "fire slugs."
- You alright, man?
You don't look so hot.
- Do not mix tequila and
cock fighting, ever, boys.
- Well, that's funny,
because I had nine Vodka
crans last night myself,
and I feel great.
I also got up, ran seven
miles, and meditated,
did a little manscaping,
all before 7 a.m.
- Did you get your scrotum, too?
- Yes.
(lively rock music)
- I brought you a gift.
- [Gillian] What?!
- Don't feel bad if you
didn't get me anything.
- I'm so, I'm humiliated.
You've really shown me up.
- Okay, here it is.
- Ho ho, oh ho ho, my God.
- So that's us on the
cover of TV Tonight,
and that's me way in the front
doing my signature pose.
And then that's Gillian.
They put her, like, in the back.
And then the dog's even
in front of Gillian.
- Yeah, this is amazing.
I feel like I should sign this.
Like, "You'll always
be Fatty to me."
- (laughs) That's good.
- Do you have a pen?
I'll sign it right now.
- No, no.
You don't need to
put that on there.
- Can we just put this down here
so it's not in the
frame for the interview?
- Okay, sure, sounds good.
- Thank you so much.
- You know, maybe we
could put it here.
- How do you not have
Wi-Fi at the pool?!
- Hey, um, I know
I'm the new guy,
so maybe I don't get it,
but why are you
all so miserable?
- What are you talking about?
- Just get me the
fucking audition.
- We get to talk to movie stars
in beautiful hotels with
free food for cash money.
Most people would
kill for that chance.
- My young, sweet Padawan.
We'll get you jaded yet.
(lively rock music)
- Yeah, I guess my big break
was when I got into Juilliard.
Do you remember when
we auditioned together?
- Yes.
- Oh, my God, how
crazy would that be
if you had gotten
in instead of me?
We would have just,
like, swapped lives.
- Ew. Gross.
- I always wondered
why you didn't get in.
Do you think it's 'cause
you can't cry on cue?
- No, I can cry on cue.
- You can?
- Yeah, I didn't want
to go to Juilliard.
It was, like, too, bleh, stuffy.
I wanted to go to City College.
- Why don't you just,
like, cry on cue now
if you can do it?
- [Britney] I
know, I'm going to.
- You just look like
you're squinting.
- Hold on.
- Okay, I'm gonna
give you a hint.
I do it all the time.
Just think about your career.
- But you have a great career.
- No, I think about your career.
It's like...
(sniffs)
I'm sorry.
Like that.
- Um, so it was so
good to see you.
- Yeah, you, too.
- Give me that, please.
She's just about as sweet
as a fucking kick in the balls.
- [Man] How'd it go?
- [Britney] Stop!
I hate myself.
(lively rock music)
(lively music)
- [Voiceover] Between
love and loss.
Between men and women.
It always begins
with a first date.
Gillian Jacobs.
First Date.